[Music]
a computer program guides a plasma torch
to cut out precisely sized slots in a
sheet of high-grade steel the slots will
house the illuminated numerals and
indicators like arrows a worker then
feeds narrower strips of steel to a
press that bends back the edges to
create tabs these strips will serve as
the sides of the scoreboard and the tabs
will be used to install them he fastens
four strips to the back panel he then
attaches the plasma cut front panel to
complete the basic structure of the
scoreboard the next worker sprays a
powder paint coating onto the entire
scoreboard then it's into a giant
convection oven for about 14 minutes to
cure the powder paint the result is a
tough powder paint skin that will make
it possible for the scoreboard metal to
weather the elements they're now ready
for working parts like LED light studded
digit boards a data transmitter and
receiver he connects the receiver to the
power source and installs it inside the
cabinet there are several light studded
digit plates on a scoreboard each can
flash any number he wires them in a loop
interconnecting them and what's known as
a daisy chain configuration he also
plugs in a ribbon style cable to link
the digits to the scoreboards processing
module he inserts the digits in the
slots on the front and shields them with
a sheet of transparent polycarbonate he
confirms that the wiring is good and
that all the numbers light up he
connects the wireless computer
processing module to the numbers and
also wires it to a power source he
mounts the module to a panel that will
then be installed through the back of
the scoreboard cabinet with all the
lettering now in place the numbers on
the board will mean something to the
crowds in the stands